china will jetzt handeln und zwar gegen
killer asteroiden was immer klarer wird
wir sind einem ständigen bomba der more
gefährliche asteroiden ausgesetzt 2 sind
es im schnitt pro jahr
meistens werden sie gar nicht gesichtet
und gehen in unbewohntem gebiet nieder
china kann gefährliche asteroiden mit
eigenen raketen vom kollisionskurs mit
der erde ablenken das ist das spannende
ergebnis einer simulation des china
national space science centers könnte
china damit im fall der fälle das leben
auf der erde retten klicks und science
in future
hier gibt's drei mal pro woche spannende
science videos abonniert den kanal und
aktiviert die glocke nur so verpasst ihr
nichts los geht's herzlich willkommen
china will die welt retten und schlägt
dazu eine neue technik vor
mit der killer asteroiden auf
kollisionskurs mit der erde abgewehrt
werden könnten immer wieder kommen hast
du in unserer erde gefährlich nahe
zweimal pro jahr dringen sogar große
brocken in die erdatmosphäre ein
wie die stiftung 611 2014 bekannt gab
die stiftung hat sich zur aufgabe
gemacht schwerer als soliden einschläge
zu verhindern doch meistens können diese
einschläge nicht beobachtet werden 2009
10 gelang es ausnahmsweise das
eindringen eines zehn meter brockens so
beobachten
er explodierte über der beringsee mit
der energie von zehn hiroshima
atombomben selbst kleine asteroiden
können also absolut verheerende folgen
haben und so arbeiten forschungsteams
weltweit mit hochdruck daran mit neuen
technologien diese gefahr zu bannen denn
das risiko besteht dass potenziell
gefährliche asteroiden auf der erde
eingeschlagen und ein einschlag wäre je
nach größe des brockens und
einschlagsort verheerend so beschäftigen
sich auch astronomen und astronomen in
china mit dieser thematik was wäre im
fall der fälle zu tun wenn wir
feststellen dass sich ein asteroid auf
gefährlichem kollisionskurs mit der erde
befindet werden wir überhaupt in der
lage diese gefahr die das komplette
leben auf der erde mit einem schlag
auslöschen könnte zur bahn fachleute vom
china national space science center
haben sich genau dieses
worst-case-szenario genauer angeschaut
und am computer simuliert dabei haben
sie erforscht wie sich ein asteroid auf
kollisionskurs ablenken ließ
23 chinesische langer marsch 5 raketen
wären demnach dafür notwendig um einen
asteroiden wie ben abzulenken und damit
das leben auf der erde zu retten wäre
realistisch ist dieses szenario könnte
diese technologie auch in der praxis
eingesetzt werden und welche
herausforderungen und gefahren birgt
diese idee die erde ist ständig bedroht
von kollisionen mit erdnahen asteroiden
und je nach größe des brockens könnte
ein asteroideneinschlag wirklich
verheerende folgen haben fliegende
trümmer tsunami wellen und schlimme
erdbeben etwa könnten ein großteil des
lebens auf der erde auslöschen
forschende plädieren deswegen immer
wieder für eine bessere weltweite
zusammenarbeit und den aufbau eines
koordinierten frühwarnsystems monatlich
werden etwa 150 neue hast du jeden in
der nähe unseres planeten aufgespürt in
der sogenannten near earth objects liste
sind mittlerweile etwa 20.000 objekte
aufgelistet doch klar ist auch dass vor
allem kleinere asteroiden bisher noch im
verborgenen blieben und wie sie noch gar
nicht auf dem schirm haben und dennoch
gehen auch von ihnen hohe risiken aus
vor die augen geführt hat uns das
beispielsweise auch der sogenannte
chelyabinsk asteroid der mit einem
durchmesser von nur 20 metern zwar vor
acht jahren 2013 ganz überraschend die
stadt tscheljabinsk im russischen ural
getroffen hatte
niemand hatte das kommen gesehen und
1500 menschen wurden verletzt der
astrophysiker chris collins vom imperial
college london hatte in einer studie die
wahrscheinlichkeit dafür ausgerechnet
dass in den kommenden 100 jahren 100
meter große asteroid auf der erde
einschlagen wird und diese liegt demnach
bei einem prozent und das ist ein sehr
ernst ist ein großes risiko und das
risiko dass ein größerer ast reden wie
zum beispiel wenn in den kommenden 100
jahren auf der erde einschlägt die dem
wissenschaftler zufolge bei immerhin 0,1
prozent laut nasa wäre mit globalen
konsequenzen zu rechnen sobald es sich
um einen asteroiden mit einer größe von
mehr als einem kilometer handelt dann
wird im zweifelsfall nicht nur eine
millionenstadt zerstört sondern das
meiste leben auf der erde und es gibt
tatsächlich so einige kandidaten die
astronomen astronomen weltweit ganz
genau im visier haben so zb neben ben j
er gilt nach einschätzung der nasa als
potenziell
wähle ich auch wenn das anschlagsrisiko
bislang vom forschenden weltweit als
eher gering gilt er wird auf mehr als
4,5 milliarden jahre alter geschätzt und
ist sehr kohlenstoff reich die nasa
hatte mit osiris rex bereits im herbst
des vergangenen jahres 2020 proben von
benno gesammelt die wahrscheinlich 2023
auf der erde ankommen werden und einige
geheimnisse über den asteroiden
offenbaren bereits jetzt steht fest
beispielsweise in den jahren 2009 135
und 2167 könnte wenn du der erde
tatsächlich gefährlich nahe kommen und
das hätte mit einem durchmesser von 500
metern und einem gewicht von 87
millionen tonnen fatale folgen
beim aufprall würde er nach berechnungen
der nasa wohl eine energie achtung von
80.000 atombomben freisetzen das
entspricht einer kinetischen energie von
1200 megatonnen uns bleiben demnach also
noch gute 100 jahre um gegenmaßnahmen
für diesen möglichen asteroideneinschlag
zu erarbeiten und genau daran tüftelt
die behörde namens planetary die fans
team der nasa bereits mit hochdruck
stichwort hemmer
das steht für high velocity estate mit
migration mission for emergency response
wege ein neun meter langes und knapp
neun tonnen schwere raumschiff das mit
einer delta 4 gw in den weltraum
gebracht werden soll es könnte nicht nur
als transportmittel für eine atombombe
dienen sondern auch als rammbock
beispielsweise für benni denn ein oder
mehrere kleine schub sagt könnten den
asteroiden zu einer kursänderung anregen
und selbst wenn diese erst einmal nur
minimal wäre könnte sie den kurs mit
einer gewissen vorlaufzeit im laufe der
zeit immer weiter verschieben
doch erst einmal müsste das raumschiff
gebaut werden die mission und die
flugzeit geplant werden und je mehr zeit
vergeht desto schwieriger gestaltet sich
dieser plan zehn jahre vor dem
errechneten einschlag von benny bräuchte
man schon bis zu 53 hemmers um seinen
kurs zu ändern
oder aber man geht doch mit einer
atombombe gegen ihn wobei es hierbei
auch wieder einige risiken gibt denn
könnte in mehrere teile aufgespalten
werden die dann weiterhin kurs auf die
erde nehmen
und wie bei einer schrotflinte wir haben
die chancen dann höher das ein großer
brocken die erde trifft und so ist die
wissenschafts community eigentlich im
großen und ganzen einig darüber dass der
sogenannte kinetik inspektor die einzige
realistische möglichkeit wäre die bahn
eines asteroiden zu verändern
auch chinesische wissenschaftlerinnen
und wissenschaftler haben jetzt in einer
studie ausgabe die wir uns vor
asteroiden auf kollisionskurs schützen
könnten
die fachleute vom national space science
center mit sitz in peking haben eine
raketentechnik vorgeschlagen um den kurs
eines solchen brockens entscheiden zu
ändern dazu schreibt einer der
beteiligten wissenschaftler
min coly hast du ihnen einschläge
stellen eine große bedrohung für alles
leben auf der erde da die ablenkung
eines asteroiden auf einem
kollisionskurs ist entscheidend um diese
bedrohung zu mindern
in ihren simulationen nahmen die
fachleute die daten von benny als
grundlage so konnten sie dann
herausfinden dass 23 raketen des typs
langer marsch 5 notwendig wären diese
müssten dann gleichzeitig auf solch
einem asteroiden einschlagen in den
simulationen kam heraus dass dieser
anschlag dazu führen würde dass solch
ein asteroid vergleich mit bento dann
von seinem ursprünglichen kurs abgelenkt
wurde
wie eine billardkugel würden die raketen
den asteroiden dabei also aus seiner
bisherigen flugbahn schießen so die
berechnungen den vorschlag aus china
kommentiert der wissenschaftler allen
fitzsimmons der vorschlag die oberstufe
der trägerrakete zu einer lite rakete zu
machen um einen asteroiden abzulenken
ist ein recht nettes konzept dennoch
müsste solch eine mission im vorfeld
natürlich noch genauer durchdacht werden
diese technik funktioniert derzeit also
eher in der theorie und eher weniger in
der praxis doch china setzt große
hoffnung auf die langer marsch
trägerraketen die diese sollen
beispielsweise den transport von modulen
für chinas raumstation und den start von
sonden zum mond und mars übernehmen
bereits seit fünf jahren 2016 testet
china dieser gegen immer wieder sechs
raketen starts waren allesamt
erfolgreich verlaufen doch dann waren
überreste der letzten akte im mai diesen
jahres 2021 unkontrolliert wieder auf
die erde gestürzt und das sorgte
weltweit natürlich für viel kritik
und nicht nur china arbeitet an
strategien um asteroiden auf
kollisionskurs
so werden schon im herbst des kommenden
jahres möchte die nasa mit einer
raumsonde zwar erst soliden relativ nahe
an der erde abfangen die rede ist von
dort die abkürzung steht für double
action tests und die nasa will mit
diesem manöver ein spektakuläres und
neuartiges asteroiden abwehr verfahren
testen das ziel wird der erdnahe doppel
astrid 6 5 803 seien aktuell keine
bedrohung für unsere erde
das nasa manöver dient lediglich dazu
dass für den ernstfall vorzubereiten die
flugplanänderung von die dämonen den
begleiter vom haupt asteroiden dee dee
moore soll durch die 500 kilogramm
schwere raumsonde tat ausgelöst werden
die dem nasa plan zufolge am 17 oktober
2022 mit sechs kilometern pro sekunde
auf den asteroiden treffen soll auch die
europäische weltraumorganisation esa ist
mit am start auch sie plant eine
raumsonde zu demos zu schicken hera soll
allerdings erst 2023 starten und dort
folgen dann könnte sie wichtige daten zu
dem die demos den asteroiden zu sammeln
eine echte premiere der erste versuch
der menschheit überhaupt die bahn eines
himmelskörpers zu manipulieren
ob china dann schon bald folgen wird das
wird sich dann zeigen
ich meine 23 raketen gleichzeitig zu
starten das ist schon oder fast
gleichzeitig oder sehr zeitnah das ist
schon eine erhebliche herausforderung
asteroiden bedrohen die erde jederzeit
anklicken anschauen und abonnieren
diesen kanal tricks und stunts im future
einfach auf den abo button unter jedem
video klicken kostet nichts und macht
schlau bis dann bleibt dran